Halloween 2018 is filled with little
references and callbacks to the original
Halloween and its many sequels for
example take this scene where father and
son come across the Escape mental
patients not only do their white outfits
seemingly floating around this foggy
night resemble the escaped patients from
the original Halloween but listen to the
song playing on the radio you all right
this is the same song that we heard
Laurie Stroud singing as she walked away
from the Meyer's house on that fateful
day 40 years ago
I wish I had you all alone
just that
the amazing thing is this isn't even a
real song when speaking at Beyond Fest
2014 actress Jamie Lee Curtis revealed
that she just made it up which means for
Halloween 2018 they actually created the
rest of the song and recorded it just to
include this Easter egg I've gone
through the entire movie and picked out
all of its best Secrets once again I
will be joined by Halloween expert and
horror YouTuber Jimmy champagne who will
be adding even more Halloween insight
and knowledge hey everyone happy
Halloween I'm glad to be back to learn
the meaning behind the new opening title
sequence all of the Halloween franchise
Easter eggs my dark theory about Lori
shroud and so much more stick around to
the end of this video this video is
sponsored by Audible
Halloween 2018 is not a remake but this
episode of things you missed is I first
covered the movie when it was still in
theaters but since then I've noticed
many more hidden details that I'm
excited to talk about the Halloween
franchise is no stranger to Second
Chances this movie is the second attempt
at making a direct sequel to the
original Halloween the first was
Halloween 2 from 1981 which took place
the same night as the original this one
acts as if that movie never happened and
brings us into the world of Haddonfield
40 years later perhaps that's why we see
a cop playing Back to the Future pinball
before getting the call about Michael
Myers because in this movie like Back to
the Future is all about rewriting the
original timeline the Halloween timeline
is like a train map which I like to call
the Halloween Express I've done other
videos exploring alternate routes but
this time we're just going directly from
Halloween 1 to the first stop on this
line Halloween 2018. in future videos I
will continue down this route to
Halloween kills and Halloween ends
despite going in a different direction
with the plot there are still
similarities and references to all of
the other movies Halloween 2018 is the
new Halloween 2 after all it's not a
remake in the sense that it has the same
story and characters it's more of a
reimagining what if Lori and Michael did
not meet for another 40 years so lots of
aspects from the original Halloween 2
and everything else from the last four
decades do show up in a slightly
different form I'll explain further once
we get into the things you missed
the movie opens at the mental hospital
Smiths Grove one of the first images is
the pen of Dr sarte this pen ends up
being important later on we focus on it
again the next day as he's getting ready
for the patient transfer and it's the
same pen that reveals a hidden blade on
Halloween night so he can attack the
police officer and free Michael Myers
perhaps this is why there's a little
spinal cord ornament on it he's not
literally stabbing Deputy Hawkins in the
back but it is a backstab in the sense
that he betrayed his trust we see more
shots around the hospital as Dr Sartain
checks in with one of his patients it's
difficult to hear what's being said so
let me turn up the volume
foreign
he's telling the patient about how we
don't always remember our dreams
especially those that aren't recent if
you saw my episode on Halloween 2 you
know that movie is all about dreams and
what goes on in the subconscious mind
the whole movie is like a nightmare that
Lori can't wake up from I think the
doctor's dialogue is there to tell us
that in this continuity Halloween 2
could be considered nothing more than a
weird dream there is further
confirmation later when the character
Dave makes this mistake about Laurie
strode's family history
wasn't it her brother who like
cold-blooded murdered all those
teenagers no that's just a bit that some
people made up to make him feel better I
think so this is a little meta joke to
the audience Allison is clarifying that
the Halloween two plot twist where Lori
and Michael are siblings is not canon to
this new timeline Sartain takes the
reporters up to see Michael Myers and
ask Aaron the male reporter to tie his
shoelace so as not to upset one of the
mental patients who has a fixation about
untied laces I see this as another
message from the filmmakers to the
audience don't expect a stereotypical
slasher where the victims trip over
their shoelaces in life or death
situations this is the era of elevated
horror after all it's less about
outdated tropes and more about
disturbing subtexts whether they
delivered on this tied shoes promise is
debatable while it is true that nobody
trips on their shoelaces in Halloween
2018 there is a character who gets
killed after slipping and falling on a
hardwood floor but the moment is a
useful setup because the character with
the shoelace fixation Mr Tivoli plays a
bigger part in the sequel Halloween
kills Aaron brings out the original
Michael Myers mask to try to elicit a
response but everyone besides Michael
seems to get riled up which leads us to
the opening credits the class Halloween
title font is back after being absent
from everything after Halloween 4. the
opening credits introduce Andy madichak
as Allison Lori Stroud's teenage
granddaughter it's her first role just
as the world was introduced to Jamie Lee
Curtis for the first time with Halloween
this is the first of many examples of
Allison filling the shoes of Lori Strode
in this movie you'll also notice the
jack-o-lantern riding in Reverse this
may sound like the name of a
post-hardcore band but the image
represents Michael Myers Rising back up
to prominence after 40 years in fact the
design of the jack-o-lantern is very
similar to that of the original movie
which many have suggested looks like
Michael in profile holding up a knife
after having no luck with Michael our
British reporters try to get Lori and
her reaction to his impending transfer
to a new facility he'll be locked away
until the end of his days that's the
idea this is word for word what Loomis
said about his plan to sedate Michael
said he can barely set up during his
trial in the first film there
I know Lori thinks that Dr Sartain is
the new Loomis so much so that she
outrights says so as if she were an
audience member watching this movie
but in many ways Lori is the new lumens
be it her Stark belief that Michael is
nothing more than evil her obsession
with destroying him her willingness to
pull up and scream at trick-or-treaters
who just end up seeing her as a senile
old lady or her resourcefulness to shoot
and blow up Michael there are certainly
a lot of parallels we're introduced to
her family shortly after her son-in-law
Rey is setting a mousetrap under the
sink I think this is a foreshadowing of
the ending where it's revealed that
Lori's house is one big trap for Michael
Myers that cage maybe it's a tram pretty
sure it's still a cage though when
Allison and her friends walk to school
the whole scene is an homage to a scene
from the original where Lori walks home
with her two high school friends at one
point Dave stops and blows up a pumpkin
with a firecracker happy Halloween
this moment foreshadows the end of the
movie where Lori drops the same line
before releasing the flare into the
basement to blow up her masked adversary
happy Halloween Michael
thank you
[Music]
Halloween is back this year with a brand
new installment and if you've been with
the Halloween franchise for a while you
might remember the novelizations that
came out alongside Halloween's one
through four for the new 40 year Trilogy
the novelizations are back but this time
you can get them on Audible each
novelization expands on what we saw in
the movie The Halloween 2018
novelization goes into the financial
lows of Smith's Grove the Lost journals
of sheriff bracket and even what
happened to the Myers house over the
years audible offers an incredible
selection of audiobooks across every
genre from bestsellers and new releases
to celebrity Memoirs Mysteries Thrillers
motivation Wellness business and more
you'll discover exclusive audible
originals from top celebrities renowned
experts and exciting new voices in audio
members get a free title every month or
two if you're an Amazon Prime member
those titles stay in your library
forever regardless of membership this
month I'm reading all good people here
by Ashley flowers because horror stories
about missing children in a small town
will never stop being creepy to try out
audible premium plus free for 30 days
visit
audible.comworld or text cz's worlds to
500 500. you'll find that link in the
description audible.com
cz's world
thank you
after Allison tells about her
grandmother's history with Michael Myers
her friend Vicky suggests just ignoring
the holiday altogether how are you guys
I wouldn't celebrate either I would just
put up a Christmas tree instead
skip all over the creepy Halloween right
uh no that's a terrible idea but it
might explain why Lori's daughter Karen
wears a Christmas sweater for the rest
of the movie I know I don't have to tell
this to Halloween fans but in my last
video I got a lot of questions about
what happened to Lori's daughter Jamie
this all goes back to the timeline
because Halloween 4 never happened in
this continuity Jaime was never born and
Lori has a daughter named Karen instead
the scene inside Allison's class is
another homage to a classic Halloween
scene you can pretty much count on
almost every scene from here on out to
be motivated by sickening amounts of
nostalgia Allison sits in the back left
seat the same position that Lori sat in
in 1978 the lesson is about fate just as
Lori's was guess they haven't updated
the curriculum lately they also did this
exact same thing in H2O already the
twist in H2O is that Lori is now the
teacher this time the teacher is played
by another familiar voice now let's open
our books to Frankel's interpretation he
said fate took a different course
Allison's teacher is not seen but it's
actually a vocal Cameo from PJ Souls the
actress who played Linda in the first
Halloween just as her grandmother did
years before her Allison looks out the
window but where Lori saw Michael Myers
standing there ominously Alison sees
Lori waiting to meet with her this is
part of the main tenet of this movie the
idea that the roles of the Hunter and
the hunted could be reversed through
perseverance and this is what the
British reporters came to Haddonfield to
investigate in his recording Aaron poses
the question could it be that one
monster has created another later into
Halloween night Dr Sartain shares his
theory that both Lori and Michael are
vying to become the predator
Michael's pursuit of Lord is throat
be what keeps him alive
I would suspect the notion of being a
predator or the fear of becoming prey
keeps both of them alive now we're
seeing Lori has taken Michael's place as
the person standing outside the school
and the movie contains many other
examples of the roles being reversed
mostly during the finale in 1978 Lori
hides in a closet while Michael stalks
the house searching for her but in 2018
Michael is hidden somewhere in the house
and Lori is the one investigating a
shuttered closet in 78 Michael was
thrown off the balcony after being shot
by Dr Loomis he's left lying in the yard
but on closer inspection he vanishes but
in 2018 the roles are reversed and Lori
is tossed from the balcony in a scuffle
Michael sees her lying on the ground in
a familiar position but after looking
away momentarily she has disappeared in
78 Michael's face appears in a dark door
frame to scare Lori the coolest shot in
the movie but in 2018 after Karen shoots
the boogeyman it is Lori whose face
emerges from the dark to strike fear
into Michael in her Spare Time Lori is
shown to practice shooting and
essentially turns her house into a
fortress she uses mannequins for target
practice and after completely blowing
the head off this one uses the boobs as
bullseyes there's also a little kid
mannequin very cool Lori very cool
there's a nice detail after this which
is barely noticeable in the Final Cut
Lori has a big scar on her left shoulder
for more Michael cut her sleeve open
with a knife in the original movie there
is a deleted scene where we get a better
look at it she was not the only one to
take on damage that night it's when we
see Michael at the mental hospital
there's a small scar visible on his neck
this is the same spot where Lori got him
with the knitting needle all those years
ago as long as I'm bringing up deleted
scenes even they have a couple Easter
eggs in one deleted scene Aaron scares
Dana with the Michael Myers mask while
she's showering because apparently in
some alternate version of this movie
they were a couple in Halloween the
curse of Michael Myers there is also a
scene where Michael sneaks up on someone
in the shower another deleted scene
shows a dog who became a Michael Myers
victim it's a common Halloween Trope for
one of the earlier victims to be a dog
it happens in the original return of
Michael Myers Revenge of Michael Myers
and Rob Zombie's Halloween 2. Michael
and several other patients are being
transferred from Smith's Grove to
another facility the idea of the patient
transfer comes from Halloween 4 the
return of Michael Myers where Michael is
loaded into a van and the trip has a
similar outcome this time it's a blue
School Bus which is a reference to The
Purge season 1. a fellow blumhouse
production I guess this was just the
year of blue buses because they did the
blue fortnite bus and YouTube Rewind and
Mr Beast did it too fortnite and Marquez
Brownlee
is this what you wanted this was the
first Halloween title to be made by
blumhouse so they decided to cross
promote with one of their big properties
The Purge the most recent film at the
time was the first Purge and it features
a big Halloween 2018 poster in a
character's room Alison's boyfriend
Cameron is played by Dylan Arnold he's
also from The Purge the two are planning
their Halloween costumes as a couple so
we're going as Bonnie and Clyde you know
how it ended right their story ended yes
with the bullets and the bleeding that's
probably a foreshadowing of the end of
this movie sure enough it does end with
bullets and bleeding but they aren't
just going as Bonnie and Clyde Cameron
will be rocking a skirt as Bonnie and
Allison complete with necktie will be
Clyde it's Bonnie and Clyde but with the
roles reversed a symbol of the role
reversal between Michael and Laurie
where Lori becomes the Hunter and
Michael becomes the hunted to foreshadow
the switch the filmmaker speech of the
reversal of traditional male and female
roles all over Haddonfield for example
remember that kid and his father who
came across the bus crash they're on the
way home from a hunting trip a typically
male dominated activity and the kid is
complaining about how he's upset that he
had to miss his dance class A typically
female activity there are three main
love interests in the movie Al boyfriend
Cameron Vicky's boyfriend Dave and
Karen's husband Ray they're all kind of
[ __ ] boys Cameron throws his
girlfriend's phone in Pudding because he
can't have her attention Dave lets his
girlfriend go upstairs to investigate a
strange noise instead of him and it
leads to her getting killed would you go
look do I have to and Rey lets his
mother-in-law Take the Lead while he
does nothing to protect the family none
of these so-called men take any
initiative in the relationship Dave even
puts a special emphasis on the date when
he and his girlfriend are going to lose
their virginity and gets a tattoo of it
on his shoulder I don't know why but to
me that just sounds like something that
a 15 year old girl would find romantic
now nobody's saying that being a girly
boy is a good or bad thing my only point
is that traditional gender stereotypes
have existed for millions of years and
these characters ain't it I'll pop your
cherry I do not want to know what that
entails also Allison's clawed costume
plays into her becoming the new Lorry
she starts suited up with the Blazer hat
and time but as the night goes on she
loses any accessories that might be
slowing her down and then the final shot
she's left with a blue button-up shirts
with the top two buttons undone which
leaves her looking a lot like Lori did
when she was Alison's age in 1978.
during a dinner to celebrate Allison's
academic achievement there's this kind
of bizarre picture of a white horse in
the restaurant The White Horse was part
of a big metaphor in Rob Zombie's
Halloween 2. this is either a reference
to that or just they they wanted a
picture of a horse in the restaurant
Laurie is also depicted in the scene to
have kind of a drinking problem just
like her character during the restaurant
scene in H2O Allison's dad also talks
about how he used to know Cameron's
father Lonnie Elam Lonnie is actually a
minor character in the original
Halloween he's one of the kids who
teases Tommy Doyle about the boogeyman
we see more of him later in Halloween
kills it is not long after her arrival
that Lori goes into freak out mode which
leads into a flashback where we see what
it was like for Karen growing up and the
house contains a ton of hidden secrets
foreign
[Music]
shows up late to the dinner and she's
acting a little strange she's emotional
after seeing Michael during the hospital
transfer
she calls him the shape if you're a
Halloween fan you know that the shape is
Michael's character name and the end
credits of Halloween one two and six I
believe this is the first time a
character refers to him as the shape in
Universe though I kind of like that they
acknowledge that somebody actually calls
him that without spoiling the Mystique
it's still up to the viewer to decide
what the shape really means they have to
send Lori home and Karen finally tells
her daughter what her childhood was like
there are a ton of cool details in
Karen's room next to the window we can
see a little bit of this poster frame
the James ensor painting you can get a
better look at it when we come back to
this room at the end of the movie where
we can also see the black globe on the
desk and the hat hanging on the wall all
three of these are items that Lori had
in her room as a teenager and held on to
over the years there's another scene
later on where Lori shines a flashlight
into the room and we see a heart-shaped
pillow another Relic from Lori's room 40
years ago before I move on there are a
couple more points that I want to make
about the kid who discovered the crashed
patient transport bus I'm really getting
my mileage out of this kid he's in the
movie for like two minutes and I already
pulled three things he missed off of him
after getting out to look for his dad he
re-enters the car where Michael Myers is
now waiting for it Michael chokes him
from behind this is the exact same way
that Annie Brackett died in her car in
Halloween 1978. as Michael slams the kid
against the window we get a rare Glimpse
at his face and you can see his left eye
has that clouded Overlook that you
sometimes see with a blind person this
is the eye that Lori poked out with the
coat hanger at the end of the original
it's a little hard to see in this movie
so here's a behind the scenes photo one
of the things I've been keeping track of
in each of my Halloween things you
missed episodes is the location of
Haddonfield within the state of Illinois
the original took place around the
southern tip near Hardin County but both
sequels Halloween 2 and Halloween 2018
Place Haddonfield in Warren County off
to the West the next day is October 31st
Halloween it's the best day of the year
our British reporters have decided to
visit the gravesite of Judith Myers
whose headstone has been restored to its
rightful plays I noticed this one big
recognizable gravestone that says
Sinclair because I remember looking into
this when I analyzed Halloween 1 to see
if it was anyone important it wasn't but
the fact that this is here in 2018 means
that they either went back to the exact
same spot or created a graveyard set
with great attention to detail either
way job well done by someone if anyone
is an expert on trees let me know if
it's possible that this skinny tree
could have grown into this massive
chunker of a tree in the 40 years
between these movies sorry for calling
it that I got a little carried away
[Music]
another similarity between the films is
the groundskeepers in the first one the
guy tells Loomis the story from the
nearby Town Russellville in this one the
groundskeeper talks about her cousin who
works in another Cemetery in a nearby
town that morning Deputy Hawkins
discovers Michael Myers is one of the
escaped mental patients on the document
he's holding the patient is listed as
Michael a Myers the middle initial a
stands for Audrey which is a reference
that not many viewers know about the
original Halloween was filmed in 1978
and released that same year it became
very popular so in 1980 NBC bought the
rights to air the film on television it
was only 91 minutes so NBC asked John
Carpenter to film a few additional
scenes to fit a two-hour time slot so
they could show more commercials that's
where they reveal Michael's middle name
Audrey I have no choice but to remand
Michael Audrey Myers to the Smiths Grove
Warren County sanitarium next we've got
another set that pays homage to scenes
of Halloween past the gas station that
Aaron and Dana fill up at brings to mind
the gas station that Dr Loomis stops at
in Halloween 4. this is where Michael
attacks a mechanic to steal his jumpsuit
in both movies if you look closely
Michael is actually the driver of the
brown truck that pulls up on the far end
of the parking lot Michael also hijacked
a brown car in Halloween we can actually
see him crossing over to go into the
service shop while Aaron has his back
turned then again when Dana steps into
the store if you look through this
window Michael can be seen attacking the
mechanic in the background next to where
Aaron is refueling a red van pulls up
from Resurrection Church and there's a
strange woman inside this may be one of
our only references to the eighth
Halloween film Halloween resurrection
from 2002.
I also want to note that when Michael
Myers stranded Dr Loomis at the gas
station in Halloween 4 it was a strange
Reverend whose car was decorated with
religious stickers who picked him up
before meeting the Reverend he tried to
hitchhike with some cheerleaders in
convertible but they left him in the
dust when he got close there is a
deleted scene from Halloween 2018 that
seems to reference this moment but it's
definitely referencing another moment
listen to what the cheerleaders are
chanting
I guess some traditions never die
because this one goes back to the first
Halloween
there are so many similarities between
these scenes in both movies characters
start talking about the Halloween dance
immediately after walking away from the
cheerleaders the high school sign has
been updated but they're still short on
black letters so they use a few red ones
details like this are why this movie is
considered a recall by fans it's
technically a sequel but it feels like a
remake with how repetitive it is at the
time I compared it to Star Wars the
Force awakens which basically does the
same thing it's a recall of the original
Star Wars Jurassic world was a recall of
Jurassic Park all three of these were
insanely profitable so now recalls are
everywhere so the homages callbacks
whatever you want to call them they just
keep coming like every 45 seconds or so
Dana steps into the ladies room where
she's attacked by Michael Myers that's a
reference to Halloween H2O 20 years
later where'd that same thing happened
Aaron comes in to save her but he gets
his face bashed into the bathroom wall
that's a reference to the Halloween
remake directed by Rob Zombie I find it
somewhat interesting that Michael bashes
in the face of this reporter in order to
regain his iconic phase or at least
William Shatner's iconic phase yeah I've
never stopped thinking about this guy in
my original videos who said said Mike
eel does not have Shatner's face it's
the other way around what the hell are
you on man suppose Shatner's mom could
somehow dictate how her baby's face came
out she would also need time travel as
Shatner was born in the 30s almost 50
years before Halloween came out with
Michael's costume complete he's ready to
do some trick-or-treating I hope you're
not tired of the constant callbacks to
previous Halloween movies because this
next part is something I like to call
the Halloween 2 sequence 3 minutes and
45 seconds of pure Nostalgia prawn for
Halloween's 1981 sequel it starts with
these two kids the one on the left is
dressed up as a pirate Halloween 2 had a
pirate kid who went to the hospital
after getting a razor in his Halloween
candy the kid on the right is a cowboy
holding a Boombox on his shoulder and he
bumps into Michael but Michael ignores
him and continues on his way this exact
thing happens in Halloween 2 before
Michael makes his way to the hospital
then Michael goes between these houses
to Snoop around you can hear some kids
singing in the background
dollars
[Applause]
this is actually another Halloween one
reference it's the same chant that we
hear at the very beginning right after
the opening titles
[Applause]
[Music]
then Michael goes into the shed and gets
a hammer the first weapon he acquires at
the hospital in Halloween 2 is a hammer
I think the existence of the Halloween 2
sequence goes back to what I said
earlier because this movie represents
the start of a new timeline Branch this
is the new Halloween 2 in a sense in H2
Michael broke into the l-rod's house
where Mr Elrod is watching TV the TV is
also on here in 2018 but the program is
the 1982 Series voyagers this show is
about a pair of Time Travelers who go
back to repair errors in world history
in other words they are altering the
timeline just as David Gordon green
Danny McBride and Jeff Bradley are
rewriting the timeline of the Halloween
franchise by taking out plot points that
they consider to be errors such as Lori
and Michael being related by blood
Halloween 2018 in a way reminds me of
Stephen King's 11 22 63. you can go back
and change certain events but there are
still inevitables that are going to
happen no matter what which is why the
hell following two sequence continues
with even more things you missed
[Music]
Michael's next victim is Mrs Elrod a
woman in a pink bathrobe with hair
curlers making a ham sandwich she is an
homage to Mrs Elrod the woman that
Michael steals a kitchen knife from in
Halloween too
Mr Elrod
are you okay we don't see Mr Elrod in
Halloween 2018 but there is a reference
to him later on when Alison's friend
Oscar is drunk in the Elrod's backyard
happy Halloween Mr 2018's Mrs Elrod is
not as lucky as her H2 counterpart and
after finishing her Michael continues
through the house where we hear a crying
baby but Michael does not bother going
after the baby which may be a nod to the
original and the 2007 remake where
Michael ignores kids and babies during
his spring outside a couple dresses a
doctor a nurse are leaving their house
my stethoscope Halloween 2 takes place
at a hospital in Haddonfield so you can
bet there are plenty of scandalous
nurses there as well this is also a
setup for Halloween kills where these
characters would come back in a bigger
capacity but instead of going after them
Michael turns to his right and stares
through the window at this woman talking
on the phone to someone named Sally
Mrs Elrod's neighbor in Halloween 2 is
also on the phone with a girl named
Sally
siren's coming judging by the
conversation this woman is also learning
about the latest incident in Haddonfield
during this phone call
and in both movies Michael sneaks up
with a little surprise wow
[Music]
and that is the three minutes and 45
seconds that I collectively refer to as
the Halloween 2 sequence after that it's
straight back to Halloween one memories
no Halloween recoil would be complete
without at least one babysitter since
the only reason that Lori and Annie ever
encountered Michael Myers was because
they were babysitting across the street
from each other this time Vicky is
babysitting a kid named Julian or as I
like to call him the best character in
the movie her boyfriend is already on
the way to join her for a spicy evening
and Allison and Cameron are supposed to
stop by after that she's setting up a
very similar scenario to what went on at
the Wallace household in 1978 where
Annie invites her boyfriend and Linda
and Bob use the house to get busy
however like in Halloween 1 things don't
go according to plan while Allison and
Cameron are attending the Halloween
dance presumably the same dance that
Lori hoped Ben tramer would take her to
Allison sees Cameron kiss another girl
and she storms off causing him to chase
after her I'm not sure if this is an
intentional reference or anything but it
sure is a lot like this scene from
Halloween 4 where Rachel Carruthers gets
upset after seeing the boy that she's
interested in with the sheriff's
daughter who's wearing this cops do it
by the book shirts and basically nothing
else as a result they break up so the
after party is limited to just Vicki
Dave and Julian oh and one other guest
they're called and we hear the following
communication go out over Police radios
this is another little Easter egg for
movie fans the original Halloween was
filmed in and around Pasadena California
and 707 Meridian Avenue was the address
of the Myers house you can still visit
it and many locations from the movie
like the corner store and the Strode
house speaking of the Meyer's house when
I made my initial video in this movie I
assumed that the dollhouse in Karen's
room was a replica of the Myers house
Halloween 2018 was still in theaters at
the time so I didn't really have the
opportunity to compare it and it does
look kind of similar but upon closer
inspection it's clearly not the Myers
house doesn't have these Dormers it
doesn't have a window above the front
door and the inner layout is not similar
at all to what we see from Halloween's
opening it's not the Myers house but
that didn't stop certain websites that
like to steal my writing from saying
that it is without actually checking for
themselves no surprise is there
interestingly there's another little
light blue house in the background
during the interview scene in Lori's
living room it is also not the Myers
house but it's not identical to the
dollhouse either I think the dollhouse
just represents Karen's childhood Karen
always wanted to be a normal kid but
Lori wanted to train her for combat at
the end of the movie The Dollhouse is
lit on fire after Karen uses her
training to help defeat Michael the
image represents Karen trading a normal
childhood for protection all of these
years later one Halloween film that
doesn't often get referenced is
Halloween 3 season of The Witch because
it's the only one that's completely
disconnected from the rest of the
franchise the movie is about the mystery
of an evil mask making company known as
silver Shamrock this scene in Halloween
2018 shows trick-or-treaters wearing the
three silver Shamrock masks skeleton
jack-lantern and witch Deputy Hawkins
shows up at the house Vicki has been
babysitting at outside of which we see a
clothesline covered in hanging white
sheets you'd be hard-pressed to find
anyone who doesn't use a machine to dry
their clothes in 2018. so I see this as
a slight nod to the original where
Michael Myers stalks Lori from behind a
clothesline when I covered the original
Halloween on things you missed I talked
about how this is part of a psychosexual
metaphor but in just about every episode
since then I've pointed out more
examples of hanging sheets it's pretty
much become a Halloween Tradition at
this point to have them show up
somewhere in the movie another use of
white sheets both in the original
Halloween and this movie is the bedsheet
ghost costume this time instead of using
it as a disguise it's used as a red
herring Michael drapes it over Vicky's
corpse for Deputy Hawkins to discover
Vicky is also set up in a chair next to
a fish tank it's like when the nurse
discovers what Michael did to Dr Mixter
in Halloween 2. next Hawkins goes
downstairs to find a Dave who is pinned
to the wall with a knife the same faith
that Bob Sims suffered in Halloween if
all of these repeated scenes in Oman
weren't enough there were also numerical
references to other Halloween movies the
cop car that shows up for reinforcements
is number 1078 the babysitter murders
took place in October of 1978. Deputy
Hawkins vehicle is 1098 so that would be
the month that Halloween H2O took place
October 1998 and yes that means this
movie is technically Halloween h4o 40
years later can't wait for h6a Lori
shows up to Warren Karen and Rey that
they aren't safe and they leave a
message for Allison there is a police
officer waiting at your house to bring
you to us we're all going to be together
now do as I say she used these same
words 40 years prior to protects Tommy
Doyle and Lindsay Wallace will you tell
them to call the police
and me go do as I say part of the reason
this Halloween was such a big event in
the horror world was that horror movies
were at near Peak popularity at the time
this was only a year after it and two
years after lights out and many other
bangers in fact it seems the writers of
this new Halloween were very inspired by
lights out as the scene with Oscar and
the motion sensored light features
Michael at a standstill when the light
is on but he creeps up close to his
Target each time the light goes off this
is exactly how the antagonist Diana gets
you when lights out this wasn't the
first or last movie to borrow this
concept but whether this imitation was a
form of flattery or theft is ultimately
up to you to decide but I think it's
theft I was amused to see that Halloween
takes another page from lights out later
in the movie The Mannequin scene where
Lori is looking around for Michael in
the house is very reminiscent of the
factory scene at the beginning of the
feature film version of lights out after
seeing Oscar get The Virgin Suicides
treatment on the Elrod's fans Allison
runs screams for help and begs for a
neighbor to let her inside the same
reaction that teenage Lori had to seeing
her dead friends the difference is that
Allison actually gets someone a letter
inside maybe we can chalk this up to the
existence of technology in the tens that
would have allowed the neighbors to know
that Michael was on the loose and
Allison probably wasn't pranking them
the Final Act of this movie would
contain more info about the true
intentions of Dr Sartain and I have my
own theory about a dark secret from none
other than Laurie Strode
after picking up Allison Deputy Hawkins
heads towards Lori's Fortress of a house
to get her to safety when he comes
across Michael Myers he decides to floor
it and try to run Michael over the same
tactic that Rachel used at the end of
Halloween for this is where we get the
first big twist of the movie where Dr
Sartain attacks him to prevent him from
injuring Michael any further we were led
to believe that Dr Sartain was the new
Dr Loomis but in fact he may be the new
Dr win the cult leader from Halloween 5
and 6 who essentially acts as Michael's
Handler looking back there are a few
clues about Dr sartain's true Allegiance
I already mentioned the significance of
the pen but before the patient transfer
Sartain almost seems to be trying to
comfort Michael
[Music]
by your side it's already well
established that Michael is a sociopath
so there's no reason to do this it's
evidence that Sartain has grown attached
to his patients he even fights to be on
the bus most likely a sign that he had
something to do with helping the shape
make his Escape
so I've seen my duties until the end and
finally when Hawkins suggests that he's
going to kill Michael if he gets the
chance Sartain tries to convince him
otherwise even though it's clear that
they'd be risking the safety of the
townspeople remember each property of
the state he mustn't be harmed sartain's
motive is an interesting case he's a
psychologist that probably needs his own
psychologist he's become so obsessed
with understanding Michael that he sees
value in putting on the mask and seeing
what it's like to kill so this is what
it feels like the fact that he puts on
the mask himself seems to pay tribute to
the original producer's cut of Halloween
the curse of Michael Myers where Dr
Loomis discovers Dr Wynn left behind
with the iconic mask at the end of the
movie Dr sartain's characterist patient
is not a mutual however and he gets his
head stomped in the faith that he shares
with the trash guy from Rob Zombie's
Halloween 2. all of this seems to
suggest that Dr Sartain is the one who
sabotaged the patient transfer that
allowed Michael to get free it's obvious
based on his motives that he must have
had something to do with it but I find
it curious that we never actually see
the bus crash that started all of this
my theory is that Lori play a hand in it
as well we know that she went there with
a gun to see the patient transfer and
it's safe to say that she's mentally
unstable at one point she even admits
that she wanted to see Michael Escape do
you know
every
that he would escape the fact that this
part of the night is so deliberately not
shown in the edit makes me think Lori
may have cut off the bus with her car
causing it to crash in a roadside ditch
then Dr Sartain took the opportunity to
use his pen knife and fight off the
security guards or the driver as a
result the confrontation doesn't go the
way that Lori had planned and she shows
up at Allison's dinner emotionally
distraught there is a moment where Lori
sees news about the crash on television
the next day wccd nice many people took
this as proof that she didn't do it but
if you actually look at the scene she
has almost no reaction she doesn't even
turn to look at the TV which suggested
me that she already knew what happened
going back to the scene where we see her
scream who is this figure approaching
the car could this be after she's
already driven the bus off the road and
now she doesn't know what to do in my
initial video I did see a few comments
saying that test screenings did actually
show Lori is the one who caused the bus
crash but since that footage didn't make
the Blu-ray deleted scenes maybe that's
a Twist that they're saving for
Halloween ends later on there's a scene
away from the action where two cops get
into this weird conversation about ban
me sandwiches the only reason this
conversation seems to be in the movie is
to make these Ops look kind of goofy I
think it's supposed to be a parallel to
Halloween 5 the Revenge of Michael Myers
where these two cop characters are
always accompanied by this goofy circus
music it's pretty bizarre the cops are
killed in the squad car while stationed
outside of Lori's House similar to how
the Halloween five cops are killed while
stationed outside the teen Halloween
party at the farm which is also bizarre
I'm gonna throw it over to Jimmy who has
a few things you might have missed
including who this police officer
character really is the cop who brings
his own brownies is played by
Christopher Nelson and he's done makeup
effects work on everything from Avengers
Infinity War all the way down to these
new Halloween movies he also created The
Masks you see in Halloween 2018 and in
Halloween kills even the flashback mask
which I think looks really good the
ending of Halloween 2018 was not always
the ending that we have today this point
is about where this version and the
original version of the film diverge the
outcome in both versions of the movie is
pretty much exactly the same but instead
of shooting Michael in the face from the
top of the basement stairs Karen
actually shoots him on the front porch
with a crossbow and after he takes a
pretty Savage beating from both her and
Lori he stumbles off into the woods and
sits on a stomp now I haven't actually
seen the full version of the original
ending but if you look back to the
trailers for Halloween 2018 they used a
lot of the footage so you can kind of
stitch it together yourself and from
what I've heard both Lori and Michael
are in really rough shape in this cut of
the movie to the point where it's
basically implied that both of them die
but of course when Blum housed in
Universal saw how good the movie was
turning out they decided to alter the
ending a little bit to leave it more
open for potential sequels and then it
made 250 million dollars the story
continues on we get Halloween kills and
Halloween ends ultimately they did
reshoot so that the final confrontation
could go down inside the house so to set
this up Lori covers the front door in
order to try to give her daughter time
to hide in the basement when this
happens
the way that Michael reaches through the
front door for her is an amped up
version of him smashing his hands
through the shuttered closet and
reaching for Lori in Halloween after
shooting her way free Lori and Karen
take cover in the basement where Lori
has kept this old gun labeled KS for
Karen Stroud Michael would soon arrive
hey he saw us Michael here
uh wrong Michael it's kind of weird how
they didn't really think Lori's house
through the basement is located under
the kitchen and at one point she shoots
up through the floorboards at Michael
but when we actually see the kitchen
from the top side it's not floorboards
it's tile as I mentioned before the
rolls are reversed and Lori is now the
hunter this room is identical to the
master bedroom where Lori and Michael
thought at the end of Halloween but
instead of Michael coming in to find the
balcony door open it's Lori she follows
in Michael's footsteps by going to the
closet but rather than finding Michael
she discovers her son-in-law Rey his
corpse is stowed in the same position
that she found her friend Linda in in
1978. Michael emerges from the dark to
attack her and she disarms him by
jamming her thumbs into his eyes in the
original Halloween 2 she was able to
Blind him by shooting him directly in
the eyes and in the 2007 remake Michael
blinds Dr Loomis by forcing his thumbs
through his doctor's eyes after Karen's
childhood gun training pays off in a big
way Michael is knocked into the basement
by Lori when he sits up it's in the same
fashion as his recharge after being
stabbed by Lori in the Doyle's bedroom
way back when that's what's crazy about
Halloween 2018. in their quest to find
more and more classic moments to include
they end up including little mannerisms
that nobody ever paid much Minds to like
the way Allison puts her hands over her
ears after hearing a gunshot being a
trait that she inherited from her
grandmother in the beginning of this
video I discussed how Halloween 2018 is
kind of a second attempt at making
Halloween too and I think the ending
solidifies that because both movies end
with Lori playing a part in blowing up
her evil counterpart and both of these
films could have been the end of the
franchise with Michael presumably
burning to death but neither of them are
I don't know if this was intentional but
when Lori drops the flyer into the
basement I couldn't help being reminded
of the sheriff dropping the dynamite
down to try to blow Michael up at the
beginning of Halloween 5. Allison Karen
and Lori are rescued by a pickup truck
which again I couldn't help but think of
our good old Illinois boys from
Halloween 4 who pick up Rachel and Jaime
the final shot shows the three
generations of women huddling in the
back of the truck and Alison has not let
go of the night my interpretation of
this ending is that the evening's events
have turned Allison into a fighter all
her life her family is seen Laurie as
this weird paranoid old woman but now
Allison is going down that path herself
the very very last thing we experience
is the sound of breathing at the end of
the credits
it's not just breathing though it's the
sound of breathing against a mask which
we heard shortly after Michael first
laid eyes on Lori in the original at the
time this was the only proof we needed
that Halloween 2018 would have a sequel
so join me for the next episode of
things you missed where I'll be breaking
down Halloween kills and if you want to
hear why you're wrong about Halloween
2018 make sure you check out Jimmy's
Halloween 2018 Revisited and come on
he's making some great content go ahead
and subscribe to his channel if you're
excited for what is in store for the
finale in Halloween ends make sure you
subscribe to cz's world because I'll
absolutely have an in-depth video on
that one as well ring the death bell and
select all notifications and I will see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive